My story starts with a duck
pond and with this man, Thomas Young,
because about
200 years ago, he was sitting by a duck
pond watching some ducks.
And I have here a pair of ducks.
We're going to have a look
at what Thomas Young saw.
Just wind up my ducks.
What he saw, as the
ducks swam around,
was a pattern appear
in the water, which
you can see down here.
Now the pattern was caused
by ripples, on the water,
leaving the ducks, and
interfering with each other.
You can see it in a
more controlled way.
Here we have a motor
that's actually
going to cause ripples.
And it's going to pass
through two slits.
And these slits are going to
produce ripples which go out
into the water and actually
interfere, very much
like with the two ducks.
You can see a pattern emerging.
You can see, here,
along this line,
two ripples are adding up.
So you're getting
bright and dark lines.
But here doesn't look
like anything's happening.
That's because the
waves, the ripples,
have actually cancelled
each other out.
Now, this made him pretty happy.
First of all because he liked
ducks, but second of all,
because it reminded
him of an experiment
he'd done a couple of
years earlier with light.
I'm going to show
you now what he
saw with his light experiment.
Here we have something very
similar to the pond and the two ducks
and actually very
similar to that tank with water
and the two slits.
Because here we have
something that produces light.
And the light passes through
two slits, actually very close
together, because light has
a very short wavelength,
a very small wave.
So you can't actually
see these two slits,
but it's the same idea.
And then, the light passes
on and hits this screen.
You can actually
see a pattern that's
quite similar to what we saw
on the tank with the water.
And there are regions of
bright and dark and bright
and dark and bright and dark.
So this set him thinking, well,
if I saw the same pattern as I
saw on water and I know that
waves travel on water, that
must mean that light is a wave.
After all, particles
wouldn't do this.
Let's have a look at
what particles would do.
For this, I need a volunteer
with a lot of puff.
Could you come down?
Your name is?
Jay.
Could you stand here.
Now, what you're going
to do is you're going
to blow through this tube.
And here is sand.
Now, sand consists of grains,
particles, lots of them.
And they're all packed in here.
And as Jay blows,
he's actually going
to blow sand through this box,
up against these two slits.
And the sand can pass
through these two slits,
very much like two
slits we had with light.
And on the back here,
we've got a screen,
which is going to collect
the particles of sand
as they go through the slits.
So huff and a puff and
blow through the tube Jay.
Keep going.
Great.
You can do it a little bit less.
That's it.
That's great.
Thanks very much.
Go back to your seat.
I'm just going to show
you what's on the screen.
And this is it.
It's not really a surprise.
There are two stripes, very
much like the two slits.
Because of course, sand
consists of grains,
like little particles.
And they either go
through one slit
or they go through
the other slit.
And that's what you're seeing.
These particles have
gone through one slit.
These have gone
through the other slit.
So this is what sand does.
And this is what particles
do, they produce this pattern.
And it's unlike the pattern
that you get with waves.
Now, we're going to try
something a little different.
We saw the pattern
that light produced.
It's nothing like the sand.
But here, we've
got, essentially,
the same piece of
equipment as before,
but we're to turn the
brightness of the light down.
Here we have the source
of light over here.
And it's passing
through two slits.
We've had to cover this up,
because we don't want any light
to get in.
The light passes
through the two slits,
goes over to the other side,
instead of a screen over here,
we've actually got a
camera, because this detects
really low levels of light.
I'm going to see what we see.
Actually, up there
on the screen,
you can see what the
camera's picking up.
The first surprise is it's
picking up dots, blips.
This is light
travelling through this.
But it's arriving as blips,
like the sand, as particles.
So that's amazing.
But have a look at this.
If we collect up all these
blips, collected over a time
period and have a look
at what the pattern is,
we see something
quite remarkable.
The pattern you see is the
pattern that waves make.
But the light arrives in blips,
in packets, as small particles,
which physicists call photons.
So this is incredible, because
the light's travelling,
making a pattern as though it
were going through two slits.
Because remember, to make that
pattern, that wave pattern,
there've got to be two
sources, two slits.
The light's got to go
through both slits.
And yet it's arriving as a blip,
as a particle, like the sand.
This is the essence of the
weirdness of the spookiness
in the quantum world.